they're certainly not benign.
Exposure of their bodies to the chemicals produced by these devices
could be changing them in ways they may not like
and setting them up for future unknown toxicities and health problems.
You know, when I said earlier
that e-cigarettes were a perfect fit for the smartphone generation,
I was not kidding.
We live in a technology-crazed world,
where the latest device and technology gets a lot of attention
just because it is technology and because it is the latest thing.
More and more over the next few years and for the rest of our lives,
we are going to see technologies coming into the marketplace
that may not raise any health flags at first,
simply because they don't look unhealthy
or they're not a medical device.
For example, we could see devices
that may make it easier to go longer without sleep
or help us lose weight --
a personal goal of mine --
or achieve any number of other goals
that we as consumers are very, very interested in.
But many of these devices may come with unacceptable risks to our own health.
So if we want to protect our health and the health of our children,
perhaps we should get out of the habit
of automatically celebrating such new technology
and get into the habit of looking at them with a critical eye,
perhaps even through a medical lens.
Because, you know something?
Our health, the health of our children and our future generations
is far too valuable to let it go up in smoke --
or even in aerosol.
Thank you.
(Applause)